hallo herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
die dramatische Lage im alschifa
Krankenhaus in Gaza Stadt ist das Thema
das heute die Nachrichtenlage und auch
unsere tvsendung dominiert nach Angaben
der Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO
befinden sich mehr als 2000 Menschen in
der schiferklinik darunter vermutlich
mehr als 600 Patienten und rund 1500
vert
die Ärzte vor Ort waren dass die
Versorgungslage der Patienten
zusammenbreche wir widmen uns hier heute
noch mal einem hintergründigen Thema zum
Terrorangriff der Hamas aber wir
beobachten auch die aktuellen Ereignisse
und Entwicklung weiter für euch am 7
oktober hat die radikalislamische
palästinensergruppe Hamas einen
Terroranschlag auf Israel verübt wie es
um die Identifikation der Leichen steht
und welche Fake News und Leugnungen zu
diesem Terrorangriff im Netz kurursieren
darüber sprechen wir wir heute zum einen
mit der chefffororensikerin der
israelischen Polizei Michal Levin Elat
und mit ZDF konfliktexperte und
Redakteur der ZDF heute Nils Metzger und
wie immer hier bei ZDF heute live auch
mit euch da draußen vor den Bildschirm
wenn ihr Fragen zum Thema habt oder eure
Meinung dazu zum Thema mit uns teilen
wollt dann schreibt uns wie immer gerne
hier im Youtube Chat oder per Mail unten
an die eingeblendete
Mailadresse und jetzt schauen wir auf
die militärbas in Israel auf der viele
forensikerinnen und Forensiker jetzt
schon einige Wochen daran arbeiten die
Leichen des terrorangriffs des 7 Oktober
zu identifizieren warum das teilweise
sehr schwierig ist darüber sprechen wir
gleich hier sehen wir gerade wie
Mitarbeiter des Forensik Teams die
verschiedenen Leichen in Leichensäcken
in Container schieben dort werden diese
Leichen gekühlt und
aufbewahrt mehr als 5 Wochen ist der der
Terrorangriff der Hamas auf Israel jetzt
schon her und noch immer sind nicht alle
Leichen identifiziert wie es mit dieser
Arbeit vorangeht wie das Massaker
forensikerinnen und Forensiker an ihre
Grenzen bringt und darüber was die Hamas
zu diesem Angriff behauptet darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit Michal lwin lad
sie ist chefforensikerin der
israelischen Polizei guten Tag Frau lwin
lad ggen sie haben fast guten Morgen
sie haben fast rund um die Uhr daran
gearbeitet die Leichen der Menschen zu
identifizieren die am 7 oktober von der
Hamas getötet wurden wie können wir uns
ihre Arbeit
vorstellen wir haben natürlich
ausgebildete Spezialisten wir haben
natürlich Menschen die an dieser Arbeit
gewöhnt sind die die sich mit
unterschiedlichen Toten beschäftigt
haben aber seit dem 7 Oktober haben wir
Dinge gesehen die wir so noch niemals
vorher gesehen haben es geht nicht nur
um den Zustand der Leichen es geht auch
einfach um die schiere Zahl der
getöteten wir hatten hunderte von
getöteten in den Militärcamps wo wir
gearbeitet haben und wir mussten alle
individuell identifizieren wir mussten
alle Angaben abgleichen und das hat
wirklich kein Ende genommen und es war
extrem anstrengend wir haben in drei
Schichten gearbeitet rund um die Uhr und
die Forensiker sind aus dem ganzen Land
dorthinereist weil wir einfach vor Ort
nicht genug Kräfte hatten und die sind
alle vor Ort gewesen um dort diese
Tätigkeiten zu verrichten und nach einer
Woche waren wir fertig mit dem
Zusammenstellen der forensischen
zu 800 Menschen also wir hatten dann die
biometriedaten zusammen und dann haben
wir versucht diese Daten abzugleichen
mit den Angaben der Familien die wir
erhalten hatten zu vermissen und wir
haben dann ein
vergleichszentrum aufgebaut um diese
Informationen abzugleichen also die
Informationen aus den leichenhäusern wo
wir ja dann auch gearbeitet haben mit
den fororensikern und dann eben mit den
Angaben der Familien wurde das
abgeglichen und all diese Daten mussten
analysiert werden und diese Arbeit geht
momentan immer noch weiter einfach
aufgrund des entsetzlichen Zustands in
dem sich die Leichen befanden zum Teil
mussten wir lediglich mit der Asche
arbeiten und wir mussten hier versuchen
in der Asche Überreste der Menschen zu
identifizieren es war extrem schwierig
für uns für uns
alle ja das sind wirklich bedrückende
Schilderungen sie haben das gerade auch
schon angesprochen der aktuelle Stand
sind
848 identifizierte Leichen das sind ja
aber noch nicht alle warum ist das bei
vielen so
schwer es hat einfach mit dem Zustand
der Leichen zu tun die Leichen waren
nicht nur verstümmelt sie wurden nicht
nur
hauptet oder zerstückelt damit hätten
wir umgehen können aber die Leichen
waren häufig sehr stark verbrannt es
wurde sehr häufig Benzin eingesetzt um
diese Leichen zu verbrennen und das hat
dazu geführt dass wir jetzt mit Hilfe
unseres Militärs im Süden Israels dabei
sind menschliche überriste zu suchen und
einzusammeln und zum Teil ist es fast
unmöglich zu erkennen dass das
menschliche Überreste sind zum Teil sind
wir in Häusern unterwegs die vollkommen
niedergebrannt sind und hier werden
wirklich Asche
Fragmente filtriert um Knochen oder Shne
zu identifizieren und diese Überreste
kommen dann in die
forensischen Instituten zum Einsatz und
da arbeiten dann wiederum
forensica mit diesen aschebestandteilen
unden nach irgendetwas was es uns
möglich macht die Opfer zu
identifizieren die ja noch nicht
identifiziert sind und das ist etwas
ganz Wichtiges da wir natürlich auch um
unsere Verantwortung gegenüber den
Familien wissen Sie schüldern uns jetzt
zum ein wie schwierig das fachlich ist
aufgrund der Zustand aufgrund des
Zustandes der Leichen sie sagen aber
auch dass das einfach Bilder sind die
auch so ein ausgebildetes Team wie ihres
noch nie gesehen hat was macht das auch
emotional mit einem Team das zwar
schlimmes gewohnt ist aber vielleicht
nicht so schlimmes
hin
wir tun unsere Arbeit wir versuchen
einfach professionell weiterz machen wir
versuchen uns nicht in die emotionalen
Abgründe zu begeben weil das
unerträglich wäre und ich muss jetzt
hier mit ihnen darüber reden es ist
unheimlich schwierig über diese zu reden
denn wenn wir damit anfangen dann
brechen wir vollständig zusammen es gibt
keinen Menschen glaube ich
der das nicht verstehen würde wir haben
Dinge gesehen die einfach furchtbar
waren und was wir versuchen um
professionell zu bleiben um dafür zu
sorgen dass wir weiter professionell
fungieren
können haben wir Interventionen
ergriffen wir versuchen uns
zusammenzusetzen wir haben versucht die
Menschen zu schulen wir haben versucht
den Menschen zu sagen was es vielleicht
an Atemübungen gibt um sie zu
unterstützen weil wir einfach nicht
atmen konnen wir konnten einfach nicht
mehr zu Atem kommen in den ersten ein
zwei Wochen und in den ersten ein zwei
Wochen wussten wir ja dass die meisten
der
Leichen ja in irgendeiner Art und Weise
noch in gewisser Art und Weise
vollständig waren wir hatten Zähne wir
hatten Knochen wir hatten dne Angaben
dann haben wir das gemacht aber
jetzt gibt es ja zum Teil Umstände wo
wir jetzt wirklich erst verinnerlichen
was passiert ist und das sind glaube ich
jetzt die wirklich schlimmen Momente
weil ich mir wirklich Sorgen mache um
die mentale Gesundheit und natürlich
haben wir Berater wir haben
unterschiedliche
Hilfsangebote für die Mens
vor Ort aber ich bin mir nicht sicher
wie das Ganze enden wird sicherlich
nicht für alle
aber für einige bin ich mir nicht sicher
wie das enden wird es ist extrem
schwierig einer der Hamas Anführer Musa
Abu marsuk der behauptete erst kürzlich
gegenüber der BBC dass von Ihrer Seite
am 7 Oktober nur Soldaten und nicht etwa
Frau Kinder und Zivilisten und
Zivilistinnen angegriffen worden sein
was lösen in dieser Situation solche
Aussagen bei ihnen
aus ich bin ein Profi ich kann Ihnen nur
sagen was ich selbst mit eigenen Augen
gesehen habe und ich habe Babys gesehen
ich habe enthauptete Kinder gesehen ich
habe Frauen gesehen
die
Arme und Beine hatten
die also sie haben ihre Hände
zusammengehalten ich habe ältere
Menschen gesehen ich habe die persönlich
gesehen ich habe den Fuß einer älteren
Frau gesehen und ich habe sofort erkannt
also das Bein sah genauso aus wie das
Bein meiner Großmutter und ich wusste
sofort dass es hier keine Soldaten waren
das ist es nicht ich hab's ich hab es
mit meinen eigenen Augen gesehen ich
habe diese Leichen mit meinen eigenen
Augen gesehen ich bin ein Profi ich habe
keinerlei Interesse an Politik aber die
Wahrheit muss ans Licht
kommen einige Details die sie auch
gerade anprechen zu diesem terrorankrieg
die werden so zu eine Art Spielball in
diesem Krieg immer wieder werfen sich
beide Seiten da gegenseitig Fake News
vor wie gehen Sie damit um und wie
stehen sie auch zur ganz expliziten
Darstellung dieser Gewalt am 7 oktober
in
Medien ich kann das nur noch einmal
wiederholen ich bin ein Profi ich bin
verantwortlich für meine Teams hier ich
bin hier zuständig für die forensika in
Israel wir haben
rund um die Tour gearbeiten wir
waren hier in den Camps vor Ort wir
haben Fingerabdrücke genommen wir haben
DNA Abgleiche vorgenommen wir haben
Fotos gemacht der Opfer wir wissen was
wir gesehen haben ich kann mich dazu
nicht anders
äußern jetzt wurden ja kurz nach dem 7
Oktober wurde dieser Terrorangriff von
einigen palästinensischen Communities
auch international gefeiert und jetzt im
Zuge der israelischen Bodenoffensive in
Gaza thematisieren diese großen
proalästina Demonstrationen weltweit
zwar Solidarität mit der
palästinensischen
Zivilbevölkerung diesen Terrorangriff
des 7 Oktober thematisieren die jedoch
wenig bis gar nicht wie blicken sie denn
auf diese
Demonstration wissen Sie ich arbeite Tag
und Nacht
ich
arbeite Tag und Nacht ich habe überhaupt
keine Zeit
Nachrichten zu gucken ich habe mich sehr
darum bemüht mir das nicht anzusehen und
ich habe das auch meinem Team gesagt
bitte keine Nachrichten gucken bitte
keine persönlichen Nachrichten verfolgen
denn das ist unerträglich und ich
brauche Vorort Leute die professionell
arbeiten können und wir können es uns
persönlich momentan nicht gestatten
persönlich involviert zu bekommen also
involviert zu sein mit irgendetwas was
nichts mit meinem Job zu tun haben denn
sonst glaube ich bleibbe ich nicht bei
mir Frau lwin ell ich danke Ihnen ganz
herzlich für dieses Gespräch und wünsche
Ihnen alles
Gute dieses Gespräch haben wir vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet so viel also zu
der Arbeit der Forensiker und
Forensikerin die die Leichen des
Terroranschlags aktuell identifizieren
müssen welche Falschmeldung zu diesem
Angriff aktuell im netzkursieren und
welche Folgen das hat das bespreche ich
jetzt mit meinem Kollegen ZDF
konfliktxperten und ZDF heute Redakteur
Nils Metzger der uns jetzt zugeschaltet
das hallo Nils hallo Victoria Nils was
beobachtet ihr den stand jetzt der
Angriff war vor mehr als 5 Wochen was
beobachtet ihr im Nahostkrieg aktuell
für Fake News und was sind die Folgen
dieser Fake News wir erleben gerade eine
riesige Flut an Falschinformation an
Desinformationen emotionalisierten
Nachrichten wie wir sie auch bei anderen
Konflikten zum ukrainekrieg
beispielsweise oder noch davor in der
coronapandemie in dieser
emotionalisierten Art selten erlebt
haben das ist auch für für unser Team
hier eine große Herausforderung und wenn
man sich jetzt die Arbeit der der
Forensiker in Israel anschaut dann
stimmt es auch bedenklich wenn wir nicht
nur im Nahen Osten sondern auch hier in
Deutschland narrative im Netz sehen in
den sozialen Medien sehen wo dieser
Angriff auf Zivilistinnen und Zivilisten
der Hamas grundsätzlich geleugnet
wird ja also Leugnung dieser Taten die
wir ja wie wir gerade gehört haben sehr
drastisch sind beobachtet ihr denn jetzt
über diese paar Wochen die der Krieg
andauert eine Entwicklung nehmen diese
Fake news aktuell zu ja grundsätzlich
nehmen Sie sie zu es sind besonders zwei
Herausforderungen denen wir uns stellen
müssen das eine ist eine Frage der
Geschwindigkeit wir erleben so ein Tempo
an Desinformation an falsch
informformation dass wir als
ja
verifikationsjournalisten teilweise gar
nicht mehr hinterherkommen das heißt die
bis wir die eine Nachricht verifiziert
haben was teilweise auch mehrere Tage
dauern kann bis wir da verlässliche
Informationen haben sind längst wieder
die nächsten zwei drei anderen
Falschinformationen im Umlauf die
Debatte ist längst weiter gezogen der
zweite Punkt da geht es um die Kanäle
und und Netzwerke die Frage welche
welche Personen wir erreichen mit
unserer Berichterstattung viele
Desinformationen kursieren auf den
sozialen Medien auf Plattformen
Instagram tiktok Ex das für frühere
Twitter und die Reichweite
traditioneller Medien dort ist häufig
begrenzt eine Studie der Universität
Washington beispielsweise die haben sich
angesehen wie in den ersten drei Tagen
nach dem Terrorangriff wie dort die
Reichweite traditioneller Medien war
verglichen mit der Reichweite großer
anonymer breaking news Kanäle die
traditionellen englischsprachigen Medien
CNN New York Times BBC hatten da eine
Reichweite von 112 Millionen Views laut
dieser Studie die großen anonymen
breaking news Kanäle die häufig falsche
Information Desinformationen
unkommentiert weiter verbreiten hat im
gleichen Zeitraum 1,6 Milliarden views
das heißt ein x-faches und gegen dieses
Ungleichgewicht der Reichweite müssen
wir mit unseren faktenchecks Versuchen
etwas entgegen zu etwas
entgegenzusetzen ja das sind wirklich
ziemlich bedrückende und aber auch
gleichzeitig beeindruckende Zahlen du
hast es gerade schon gesagt dein Job ist
es unter anderem so faktenchecks fürs
ZDF zu erstellen und du hast uns auch
ein Beispiel mitgebracht
anem wir das jetzt mal so ein bisschen
Exerzieren können wie du in deinem
Arbeitsalltag vorgehst ich habe euch mal
dieses Bild hier mitgebracht das
angeblich israelische Helikopter zeigt
die auf das Festivalgelände des
Supernova Musikfestivals schießen würden
das wird hier gleich mal eingeblendet
genau da kennt man jetzt gar nicht so
viel wir haben uns entschieden dieses
Video nicht in voller Länge zu zeigen
weil wir diese propagandabilder nicht
teilen wollen Nils erklär doch mal wie
geht ihr jetzt an so ein Video ran was
z.B auf Ex tausendfach geteilt wird ja
diese Aufnahmen werden genutzt um zu
belegen dass angeblich die Hamas
überhaupt keine Zivilisten getötet hätte
sondern die meisten dieser Toten von der
israelischen israelischen Armee selbst
ja verantwortet werden m wir gehen dann
hin und versuchen die Originalquelle zu
finden dem Fall ist das Videomaterial
das von der israelischen Armee selbst
veröffentlicht wurde und dann schauen
wir uns selbst kleine Details in diesen
Videos an das heißt selbst diese kurzen
Videoausschnitte von wenigen Sekunden
geben lassen Rückschlüsse zu wo sie
aufgenommen wurden es sind Büsche zu
erkennen es sind Straßen zu erkennen es
sind teilweise Gebäude zu erkennen und
in sehr kleinteiliger Arbeit kann man
dann rekonstruieren wo diese Bilder
aufgenommen wurden und dass sie eben
nicht vom Festivalgelände stammen
sondern dass sie teilweise von
Zufahrtsstraßen aus Gasa heraus stammen
dass das Videoaufnahmen sind die Autos
zeigen die zurückkehren nach Gaza das
auf jeden Fall der Kontext dieser Videos
ein anderer ist als in vielen viralen
Tweets die millionenfach aufgerufen
wurden
dass das ein anderer Kontext ist und wir
arbeiten immer mit mehreren Quellen das
heißt wir analysieren nicht nur dieses
einzelne Video sondern wir schauen uns
an was gibt es sonst noch an Materialien
was gibt es an Augenzeugenberichten wie
kann man das zu einem einem Bild
zusammensetzen
das der Wahrheit
entspricht man hört jetzt aus deiner
Beschreibung des Arbeitsprozesses schon
raus das ist ähm gar nicht mal so ein
Schnellschuss den ihr da veröffentlicht
sondern du sagst es gerade ihr prüft
mehrere Quellen ihr guckt euch das ganz
genau an das dauert dann in der
Konsequenz wahrscheinlich einfach auch
länger oder genau das heißt lieber
warten wir mit unserer Analyse einen Tag
länger als eine Überschrift zu
produzieren als eine Nachricht
rauszuschicken an unsere Nutzerinnen und
Nutzer äh die sich im nachhin als falsch
herausstellt du hast uns noch ein
zweites Beispiel mitgebracht was wir
jetzt hier gleich mal einblenden und
dabei geht es um ein Foto das im Rahmen
des terrorangriffs am 7 Oktober eine
angeblich eine geborgene Kinderleiche
zeigt das sehen wir jetzt hier links
verpixelt und das wurde im Netz dann
ziemlich schnell als Fake bezeichnet und
der Beweis dafür sollte angeblich dieses
Foto eines Hundewelpen sein das dann im
Netz kursierte Nils stimmt das
die Geschichten über getötete Babys
durch die Hamas da hat sich ein
richtiger deutungskampf drum entwickelt
dass es immer wieder in Frage gestellt
wurde dieses Bild haben wir dann mit
einer Bilder Rückwärtssuche
ausfindig machen können das hat zuerst
auf der Plattform forchan sich
verbreitet
es wurde dann von großen Medien
aufgegriffen also selbst der arabische
Fernsehsender aljasera hat einen einen
Tweet abgesetzt wo er dieses Gerücht
gestreut hat dass er ein manipuliertes
Bild aber tatsächlich haben wir dann
festgestellt dass dieses hundewelpenbild
das manipulierte ist dass dieses äh Bild
der verbrandnten Babyleiche authentisch
ist wir sind nämlich hingegangen und
haben ähm das Originalbild
heruntergeladen das ist auch wichtig
denn viele Social Media Plattformen
verändern die Metadaten die im
Hintergrund von von einem Bild
existieren wenn man sie ab hochlädt das
heißt es ist wichtig dass wir die
Originalquelle haben und haben dieses
Bild dann mit äh ja forensischen
Bildanalyse Softwaren
untersucht und festgestellt dass dieser
Hundewelpen nachträglich eingefügt wurde
das kann man an der Struktur des Bildes
dann erkennen dass genau um diese
Umrisse des Hundes
dann farbliche Auffälligkeiten zu sehen
sind und das sind Möglichkeiten wie man
nachträglich Bilddateien verifizieren
kann m das ist aber eine sehr
spezifische
einzelfalluntersuchung nicht jedes Bild
kann man automatisch mit den gleichen
Methoden
analysieren wir haben zu diesem Thema
auch gleich Maline Frage aus der
Community und da fragt jemand auf
Youtube wie groß sind denn die
Auswirkungen von KI und deepfakes
aktuell in diesem Krieg und in der nahen
Zukunft mit der nahen Zukunft ist
tatsächlich die die relevante Frage der
Einfluss wird immer größer jetzt im
aktuellen Konflikt kann man noch keinen
sehr großen Effekt feststellen die
meisten Fake Informationen die im Umlauf
sind
sind größ ils Bilder die in dem falschen
Kontext gezeigt werden aber aber weniger
Bilder die komplett KI generiert
komplett erfunden sind aber das wird
definitiv eine der großen
Herausforderungen der Zukunft es gibt
auch da schon spezialisierte Software
Lösung zum Erkennen von AI generierten
Bildern aber auch die sind noch sehr am
Anfang und produzieren auch häufig
falsch positive Ergebnisse so dass man
da auch nicht absolut sicher sein
kann jetzt sind wir alle ja tagtäglich
im Internet unterwegs auf ganz
verschiedenen Social Plattformen x
tiktok Instagram und Co was würdest Du
denn jetzt unseren Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauern raten die sich jetzt fragen
wie kann ich als Userin hinter dem
Endgerät solche Fotos und Videos die mir
in die Timeline gespürt werden auch
in einfachen wenigen Schritten mal
kritisch hinterfragen mhm der die erste
Empfehlung wäre auf den Absender dieser
Nachricht zu gucken wer kommuniziert das
gerade ist das ein nam hafter Journalist
kann man den einem Medium
zuordnen oder ist das ein anonymer
Account dann ist die Frage warum ist das
ein anonymer Account wer wer steckt
dahinter was möchte er damit machen
macht verbreitet er diese
Information als Aktivist möchte er damit
Geld verdienen das heißt zu fragen woher
kommt das und so anonyme Accounts
recherchieren die meisten Informationen
kaum selbst sondern übernehmen
Informationen aus anderen Quellen das
heißt der erste Schritt wäre dann sich
zu fragen woher kommt der diese
Information was ist die ursprüngliche
Quelle gibt es da ein großes
Nachrichtenmedium was das berichtet
haben soll wenn diese anonyme Quelle
ihre Quelle nicht angibt dann ist es auf
jeden Fall ein deutliches Zeichen dass
man ihr nicht trauen sollte und was
häufig auch der Fall ist dass behauptet
wird dass ein großes Medium etwas
berichtet habe dass der Spiegel New York
Times andere Medien etwas etwas
berichtet haben wenn man aber dann in
den originalen Artikel blickt ist es
gestaltet sich ganz anders dass diese
Meldung dann falsch dargestellt wurde
und vielleicht der wichtigste Ratschlag
wäre nicht nur die Überschrift zu lesen
soziale Medien verkürzen sehr sehr stark
bieten häufig gar nicht den Raum um den
Kontext für eine Nachricht
komplett auszubreiten das heißt nicht
nur die Überschrift lesen sondern eine
ganzen
Artikel jetzt haben wir ja gerade schon
so Bilder angesehen die im falschen
Kontext genutzt werden also zum einen
dieses grüne Standbild aus dem Video
oder auch dieses
Hundewelpen Bild woher kommen denn diese
Fake News die aktuell in diesem Krieg
genutzt werden sind das alles ganz
gezielte Hamas propagandaabotschaften
m nein die Hamas selbst steckt nicht
hinter jeder einzelnen Falschmeldung es
sind viele Falschinformation die von
Ihnen oder ihr nahstehenden Gruppen
verbreitet werden ja aber es gibt ein
ganzes Ökosystem an verschiedenen
Gruppen die davon
profitieren falsch und Desinformation zu
verbreiten das können kann aktivistisch
motiviert sein aber dahinter können auch
ähm ja regierungsakteure weltweit stehen
das heißt wir erleben es häufig dass ähm
staatliche Auslandssender aus Russland
aus Iran aus aus China ähm im Umlauf
befindliche Falschinformation verbreiten
ihnen versuchen Reichweite zu geben weil
so viele Akteure davon profitieren wenn
in unseren Gesellschaften hier Streit
herrscht wenn man sich uneinig ist wenn
einfach eine unklarheit besteht darüber
was wahr ist und was falsch ist von
dieser Unsicherheit profitieren sehr
viele
Akteure wir haben hier eine Frage aus
der Community auf Youtube da fragt
jemand auch passend zu diesem Thema wie
wisst ihr denn dass es Fake News sind
wenn ihr nicht mal eigene Journalisten
in Gaza habt wir haben unsere ZF
korrespondentinnen Korrespondenten vor
Ort in Israel wir haben erfahrene Teams
von Journalisten mit denen wir auch
schon lange zusammenarbeiten auch in
Gaza selbst die für das ZDF dort
arbeiten das heißt wir bekommen
Informationen von beiden Seiten des
Konfliktes und werten das auch
entsprechend
aus und dann noch eine abschließende
Frage die neuesten Meldungen von heute
sagen die Zahl der Todesopfer in Gaza
seit dem 7 Oktober sei auf
11240 gestiegen
4630 davon sein Kinder und die Quelle
dieser Angabe ist das Gaza Media office
was heißt das wie ist so eine Quelle
einzuschätzen ja die Zahlen aus Gaza
sind tatsächlich
schwierig journalistisch zu verwerten es
sind die meisten Informationen stammen
von dem Gesundheitsministerium in Gaza
dass der Hamas einer Terrororganisation
untersteht also sie ist eine
Konfliktpartei aber das bedeutet nicht
dass man diese Zahlen grundsätzlich
nicht nutzen kann
wir versuchen Sie immer in einen Kontext
zu stellen zu erklären wo sie herkommen
beispielsweise unterscheidet die Hamas
dabei nicht zwischen
getöteten Zivilisten und getöteten
Kämpfern das heißt es ist für uns auch
vollkommen unklar wie viele dieser
Menschen ähm Hamas Aktivisten Hamas
Kämpfer sind aber vor einigen Wochen
beispielsweise hatte die Hamas eine
umfangreiche Liste äh der Getöteten
veröffentlicht inklusive der Namen und
der ausweisnummern und äh diese Liste
haben wir im Team beispielsweise
analysiert und haben versucht
herauszufinden ob es da grundsätzliche
Manipulationen in diesen Daten gibt ähm
und sind zumindest auf keine grundsätz
ich Manipulation gestoßen das heißt die
grundsätzliche Dimension der Opfer in
Gaza ist sehr sehr hoch da gibt's gar
keinen keinen Zweifel
dran wo allerdings wir sehr vorsichtig
sind sind was Opferzahlen von konkreten
Ereignis konkreten Ereignissen angeht
beispielsweise die Explosion am alahli
Krankenhaus die ja sehr sehr breit
berichtet wurde da waren die Opferzahlen
die von Hamas Institution anfangs
berichtet wurden was 500 Tote äh und in
dieser Größenordnung haben sich später
als niedriger vermutlich niedriger
herausgestellt
ähm das heißt da müssen wir malmer
vorsichtig sein
ähm ja keine hamaspraganda mit
überhöhten Zahlen zu verwenden
insbesondere wenn es gerade eine eine
aktuelle neue Situation ist auch da
lieber vorsichtig sein verifizieren zu
gucken können diese Zahlen
stimmen und wir haben noch eine
abschließende Frage aus der Community es
fragt jemand auf Youtube gibt es eine
leicht zu durchblickende Liste von
namhaften seriösen Quellen kannst du uns
abschließend noch Tipps geben woran sich
unsere Zuschauer und zuschauerinn in
diesem wirw an Informationen
grundsätzlich orientieren können
grundsätzlich bieten wir jetzt auf der
ZF heute natürlich verschiedene Arten
von News an wenn man sich schnell
informieren will haben wir unseren
Israel Palästina Liveticker wir haben
hintergründige Artikel darüber hinaus
unsere korrespondentinnen und
Korrespondenten sind in den Sozi alen
Medien aktiv dort bekommt man auch viele
Einblicke von vor
Ort grundsätzlich gibt es sehr sehr
viele Medien die gut Berichten aus Gaza
aus Vorort aus Israel
Palästina ich würde grundsätzlich dazu
raten vorsichtig zu sein bei zu großer
Emotionalität wenn jemand euch eine
Nachricht mit großer
emotionaler ja mit viel Emotion
verkaufen will ähm schaut nach
recherchiert selbst ob es dazu eine eine
glaubwürdige Quelle
gibt Nils vielen Dank für deine
Antworten und die Erklärung und die
Transparenz zu deiner Arbeit alles Gute
nach Berlin und schönen Abend noch danke
dir auch einen schönen
Abend ja und wie sich die Lage im
Nahostkonflikt im Nahostkrieg weiter
entwickelt wir bleiben hier bei ZDF
heute und bei ZDF heute live weiter für
euch dran viele viel Dank für eure
Fragen und eure Kommentare und einen
schönen Abend
[Musik]
noch